the rnc kickoff tonight
as i said it stood in sharp contrast to
the
doom and gloom america's racist
nightmare that the dnc portrayed last
week
i felt and i hope you felt this way it
was like a breath of fresh air or
maybe more accurately it felt like
millions of patriotic hard-working
americans
were exhaling a sigh of relief after a
very difficult last six months now
america isn't a country
that they were it was described of uh as
last week
no way and tonight we were reminded that
donald trump is a man
who cares deeply about the present and
future of americans of all races all
backgrounds
all creeds we need a president
who believes in the american dream like
president donald trump
at the white house my family and i sat
with the president in the oval office
and told him about meadow i got to see
who president trump really is
he's a good man and a great listener the
president also built the most inclusive
economy
ever with record low unemployment for
african-americans
and record high participation in the
workforce growing up in the deep south
i've seen racism up close i know what it
is
and it isn't donald trump now as noted
just a few moments ago
andrew pollock and herschel walker will
be here later in the hour
now on this first night of the
republican national convention i think
it's
really important to ask a simple
question has donald trump and the
republican party
done enough to justify being rehired in
november
well the democrats spent all of last
week during their disaster of a virtual
convention making the case
that the trump administration the gop
have failed the american people
five million americans infected by covet
19
by far the worst performance of any
nation on earth
more than 50 million people have filed
for unemployment this year
it's a storm center there's only chaos
donald trump is destroying our country
the future of our democracy
is at stake but the future of our
democracy is at stake
that's what's at stake right now
our democracy echo chamber well the
democrats claims were full of emotional
rhetoric very repetitive echo chamber
stuff
but it was remarkably short on facts
and policy recommendations and the
reason is very simple
when you look at the facts it's obvious
that none of our g7 peers
is doing as well as the united states
today
it's also clear that america would do
even better
if the democrats who control some of our
biggest cities and our largest states
would spend less time
complaining about trump and more time
learning from him we will build
monuments to heroes not
burn down our cities democrats refuse to
denounce the mom
and their response to the chaos defund
the police
defund border patrol and defund our
military the democrats have controlled
this part of baltimore city for over 50
years
and they have run this beautiful place
right into the ground
abandoned buildings liquor stores in
every corner i feel for local businesses
across america who are
under assault from shutdowns from riots
and now facing the terrifying prospect
of joe biden
coming after everything we've built
and all year we've been hearing from
democrats about how our friends in
canada and western europe are doing
better than we are
but again the facts say otherwise now
let's just look at what's happening for
a moment with covet
now here in the united states the number
of new daily covett infections
just hit a two-month low you heard that
lately on the other networks
meanwhile europe is seeing an explosion
of new cases
in germany in spain in italy and
elsewhere
democrats would also have you believe
that trump's extremely deft handling of
kovitz somehow
made americans much worse off than our
friends in europe
too many hard-working families have been
caught
on an economic treadmill when
unemployment is the highest rate
since the great depression back in 2016
when trump asked what do you have to
lose
well now we know our health care our
jobs
well what they're not telling you of
course is how lucky we are that trump
didn't follow europe's lead
now while the crisis of course did hurt
our economy other g7 competitors
ended up much worse off look at the data
the gdp
in q2 2020 remember we were already
significantly richer than these
countries before the crisis began
our per capita gdp was 20 000 higher
than germany's almost double italy's and
now we're managing the economic fallout
of the crisis
better than almost all of them so the
gap between us is likely to grow
now what democrats also aren't telling
you is that our recovery is going
way better than other western nations
today the s p
500 nasdaq hit all-time record highs
in other words these indices are worth
more today
than they were before the virus now this
is great
for your 401k and your iras but more
importantly the markets are one of the
best ways to
gauge investor optimism they aren't just
some poll of experts or ivory tower
economists
these are real pep people betting real
money
and they're betting on the united states
but in spite of this unbelievable
opposition this president has done what
he said he would do
taxes cut regulations reduced economy
growing
lowest unemployment 50 years who better
to lead us out of these times
than the president who already built the
strongest economy our country has ever
seen we want a chance to get ahead not
just get by
that's what president trump promised and
that's what president trump delivered
now investors clearly like what they're
seeing with trump and after hearing
democrats lay out their disastrous
designs for the economy last week
who could blame them he's going to
invest in
child care and canceling student loan
debt
joe will roll back that tax cut that i
got so we can fund things our whole
country needs
we should pour billions into private
businesses
there should be 10 solyndras meaning
there should be 10
failed investments you have to deal with
the virus
so if the scientists say shut it down i
would shut it down
i would listen to the scientist
ah he said that after the dnc of course
he'd shut it down
so now you see why the democrats were
afraid to really get into the
nitty-gritty of policy
but for four years president trump and
the republicans have proven that their
policies work better than anything the
democrats have to offer
their faith in freedom and the rule of
law
works better than the chaos that we see
tonight
in certain blue cities we'll get to
wisconsin in a bit
of course the strict regulations high
taxes that stifle
innovation in places like canada europe
and japan
the democrats didn't talk about policies
last week not really
because they don't have any ideas that
will make life better for the average
american it's just rhetoric
and rhetoric and more rhetoric
it would be a terrible error for the
american people
to change course to emulate the
disasters that are causing so much
trouble in new york and elsewhere
let's keep on the path that's working
let's vote for trump
and the republicans keep america
great how about make america even better
year after year after year
and that means an america that is free
so we can all
pursue our own happiness and that's the
angle